[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
gdg l'étudiant sapeurs bah oui bah quoi
leurs pompiers mais non pas sapeurs
pompiers sapeurs un mec t'es bien sapés
a beau je suis sûr que c'est votre style
en mai moi j'adorais le père j'adore le
fils à risque et haddock qu'est-ce qui
n'alerte avoir dit comment tu as dit
avant ça va possiblement possible faut
faire un choix
non non ça va pas être possible c'était
balancer sérieusement qu'est ce que tu
veux qu'ils rendent une fois en fuite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai déjà pour partir le jeune à nous
sommes sûrs où s'ébattent away compliqué
[Musique]
ah ouais mais 17 secondes au tour vous
êtes bon calcul mental ça peut aller
allez-y 14 +13 qu'intense 13 20
je veux y aller en étant dépassé à la
barre des 30
non c'est pas le juste prix 14 +13 c'est
moins 28 2e pas dit alors ça serait
sympa non son travail est bon aux sports
[Applaudissements]
j'étais au au musée c'est de quelques et
sur le quai d orsay
ouais non eh bien mon tableau préféré de
tous les tableaux originaux
c'est pas lui c'est génial
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
doc gynéco tu pense qu'il peut pas
gagner l'eurovision vidal âgées pas eu
le temps de changer de coach en
épluchant j'ai grillé
j'ai dit bizarre et tu voyages et qu'est
ce que tu veux changer le peu d alors
vous savez je faisais ce qu'on va faire
on va tester une dizaine de minutes pour
changer et pour l'instant on va voir la
vidéo de bilal assadi hier superbe
bâtisse et il perd en eurovision
ouais je peux nous résumer le concours
vidéo qu'est ce que c'est c'est un
concours qui regroupe j'imagine tous les
pays d'europe
bien sûr passer l'eau mais ça a lieu à
jérusalem est ont pas tel aviv raviver
la ville à jérusalem aurait dû
ah il a enlevé ses maîtres qui cia mais
c'est moi j'ai trouvé ça super parce que
c'est toi qui fait l'histoire
on a l'habitude de penser que l'histoire
est que toi que tu y ailles toi toi tu
as fait l'histoire un peu à ta façon je
crois plus à l'histoire faite par les
hommes qu'à l'histoire ali et les hommes
qui imaginent dire que l'histoire c'est
que c'est plus facile de dire que c'est
l'histoire qui fait jure thouars mais
vois-tu fait l'histoire et on n'a pas
gagné depuis 77 vous avez vous également
c'était l'oiseau et l'enfant marie
myriam abel la chanson bah oui elle est
belle à la gagner merci mais on voulait
pas ton avis sur la chanson d'oeil à
35,2 ya des millions voulait elle tourne
à vide chose ah ouais ben en tout cas il
a un super prénom euros avec nous
magnifique aime bien matt maths mais par
colis xt qui si on s'est vus non j'ai
pas fais attention tu m'as pris au
dépourvu
elles seraient connus c'est quoi odile
et je vous suggérerais on dirait un
mannequin vous savez dans une vitrine de
magasin et les gars il a une petite
ville dans son mail à nos petits bouts
tout mettre sur la même son père c'est
sûr que c'est sûr que je mélange
l'automne et les tifs jeu mais le
bonhomme s'est ouvert trop les gens
comprendront pas je te dis le moi tout
sur cette vitrine dans mes souliers et à
tous mes frères
un furet quoi qu'est ce qu'il y arrive
c'est un peu un peu plus mais hier il
s'est très vite c'est qu'on est dans sa
nature
ça c'est vous bercer de ses personnages
et l'ouverture aux beignets climatique
[Rires]
c'est un des lunettes on boit c'est bien
moi le gars franchement elles sont pas
ma voix pas mal non à ces pages est
anglais je les achète pas cher mais
frère tu sais que le truc but est
d'ouvrir une v4 sur la tête de ma mère
si vous écrivez l'a pas choisi la mer et
la d'oublier la du les essais l'équipe
[Rires]